[Music]
you seem to think this is the best one
yeah it's that time again guys and i
said to james pre-recording i genuinely
feel like this round might be the or one
of the best 12 hall of fames i'm about
to do i was laughing when i was reading
okay say let's say that
i'm ready let's go
who is scared of robin that [ __ ] runs
around gotham in booty shorts
robin is a [ __ ]
an absolute pussy-o fax he's such an
irrelevant psychic fact they gave up on
him in the batman movie yeah yeah yeah
we can't
we can't take this any further darken
this
he can't take it he's so camped which
was he in uh dark knight or the second
um dartmouth rises are
robin yeah
i'm sure at the end you know don't
remember oh at the end
i'm sure you believe he revealed his
name was robin do you remember it was
[ __ ] what's his favorite i know the
brother the 50 50 brother yeah yeah
joseph gordon yeah him yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he was robin yeah he was robin yeah
um yeah i can't remember might be rises
rises it was rises yeah because i think
batman had died yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah but i just realized like there's
nothing we could do literally nothing to
do because he's literally just wearing
battery riders
back riders and skin tights
in a cave and a [ __ ]
little some little masking so
masquerading oh my goodness and he's
literally a trapeze artist no that's his
origin story
he's a trapeze artist oh my god him and
his whole family just circus freaks [ __ ]
it up yeah
it's been years it's been years and
curtis from live island saying he
doesn't want to cuddle because he wants
to get up and make coffee for everyone
in the morning
do you oh you don't watch love island
that goes straight over my head ah
demand them that watch love island would
know
so give me context for context there's a
better called curtis and i think her
name was amy i could be wrong
in my opinion she wasn't good-looking oh
but that she loved him oh she loved him
so they were together from the jump yeah
from the jump yeah and curtis was one of
them flamboyant salsa dancers he loved
to please people christ yeah yeah he was
at the beginning
it looked as if he was infatuated with
her so they were just a couple you
thought right these men are gonna win
yeah these men are gonna [ __ ] win
yeah right bet
i think things start to unfold people
leave new galley come obviously new
dates blah blah blah he said it's
turning of course his head is [ __ ]
turning of course so that man sit down
like me and you were sitting down right
now yeah he was like she's like babes
you don't even you don't even cuddle me
in the morning before before we do
anything he's like
i hear you but i'm the kind of guy that
wants to get up out of bed and make
coffee for everyone
raw fam man said he just doesn't want to
be in her space yeah yeah yeah i hear
that fam i've always thought like
i don't care how lame the thing is
there's nothing sexy about the in any
dating show being the first couple to
pair up
it's tough it's not sexy tough it's
tough right because i know you're
risking it all i know you're risking it
i know you are i know you are but you
have to put faith in the producers that
they know what they're doing yeah
there's got to be a body they're
watching it
i know there is yeah i'm just i'm just
hopeful bro i hope you didn't get voted
out before that time oh god imagine i
couldn't imagine
and you had a thing that was damaged
yeah yeah yeah you're like nah i'm gonna
wait i'm gonna wait
i know there's a lengthening waiting for
me around the world yeah
i know this guy's just here to [ __ ] get
him out get him out my [ __ ] we need
to fight him out bro he's toxic this one
i just realized how risky typing bigger
is for white people
fam i ran to my keyboard oh does it b
and n are next to each other oh swear
right next to each other i'll swear
yeah bro
it's not worth it it's not on a qwerty
thing it's not working
[Laughter]
imagine after sex i pull my notepad out
and cross your name out
i wouldn't that's a simulation thing
that's one of the moments where you
think like what's going on what's what's
going on
she's been
baiting me out yeah wow
i've had i feel like i've had times of
that in my life where girls have
literally like
i don't know i feel like they've used me
for like
to just
tick me off do you know what i mean in
what sense though for sex or
sex other
yeah for sex like i feel like i've like
had like a weird thing with like a girl
and we have sex and then they're just
like
their mentality just like softens yeah
and they seem a bit more business-minded
you know what i mean
no oh you probably don't yeah maybe just
me then i'm sure there's definitely it
was back in uni when i was just on this
like
yeah rampant yeah
yeah yeah there was just certain girls
that like they were so so so down and
we'll bang and regardless of whether it
was good or not so good
um
they'd just be like gang cool
like yeah i like it they just seemed
like not even like oh i thought it would
be better than it was or whatever they
just seemed like it was like a cool
exchange yeah okay but like i came out
to get dick tonight
i picked you from early i [ __ ] you i'm
going home cool say for that yeah
yeah a couple of times abby it hasn't
happened bad times but there's been a
couple times where i felt a bit just
like yeah yeah it's like i felt naked
yeah
yeah they're like cool that's what's out
for mission accomplish [ __ ] cool bet
please wear cologne that matches your
face making me turn around for
foolishness
bro
that's dread
it is brother so many people sent me
that so many people sent me that
i'll send a risky text then start being
productive for no reason
risky text i promise you now
david i'm deleted i'm deleting the whole
convo and i'm launching my phone
and then from the yard needs hoovering
the wall needs painting exciting the
matting is there's
oh my god it's all about the breaking
point yeah you sent the text you've
launched your phone yeah you get on with
it
seven minutes goes by
and you and you quickly like
check your phone yeah and she still
hasn't replied yeah yeah you fall to
your knees
it's been seven minutes it's over so far
so far it's over especially if she's
seen it
it's over she couldn't have seen it she
couldn't have seen it [ __ ] over i
wouldn't have seen it
oh god you just at what we're done
exactly oh oh
risky techs are the best but the worst
and then when
15 minutes goes by she reciprocates yeah
you're jumping fan
the productivity is gone bro [ __ ]
whatever i was doing the hoover's just
on the floor chilling i'm texting my
feet are dangling my feet are dangling
we're going backwards oh bro that's
hilarious
a girl a girl would join a ps4 party and
dude's voice will go from lil uzi to
batman in seconds
fam this one sweetened me go on i got
arrested at the baby concert they
searched my bag and found 20 tomatoes
[Laughter]
that took half a second to sink in and
when it did [ __ ] me oh that's jokes can
you imagine i couldn't can you i
couldn't james i promise you now i
couldn't imagine being a security guard
can you [ __ ] imagine
you'd be so gassed with that cat yeah
you [ __ ] prick
twitter
the baby will never believe you if i'm
just if i'm just cute and i tell him he
will never believe me oh he wouldn't
know he would never believe i saved the
day for you you don't even get it people
like what shut up well you think man
paid [ __ ] 60 quid to come and see me
to throw tomorrow's at me you're a liar
you're a liar bro shut up
you would never believe him
ah i went through his phone i'm not even
his type
oh dear i bet bare women have that
that that fear of course i think both
sexes both sexes both genders yeah yeah
so this is a two-part it's a tweet and a
quote tweet
you'll ever get your ass beat before can
you guys even fight
first fight replied this by the way this
reply first fight i was in [ __ ] hit me
in the throat i didn't even know that
was an option
it's not it's not an option i could i
promise you i couldn't get hit there
fam i wanna wax [ __ ] for a living but
i'm scared i may eat one and get fired
[Laughter]
oh that's jokes that's actually jokes
imagine your boyfriend's tried to start
a football chant and nobody joined in oh
ick [ __ ] i'm pretty sure someone's
had that as a nick
i'm a sucker for deep conversations i
want to know why your hairline is that
far back
imagine someone said to you i couldn't
james i promise you know i couldn't
you know
i can't really explain this to you
properly right
have you you haven't seen broke about
mountain have you no i haven't no right
maybe i have maybe i think i have but
i've only seen him once a long time ago
keith ledgeron
jake gyllenhaal yeah bro listen
there's the first time they [ __ ] yeah
jake gyllenhaal grabs heath ledger okay
by the scruff of his shirt okay and he
finishes pouring him off yeah but he
wants it yeah yeah yeah he's never done
this with a push pull today
but jake general seemingly grabbed him
yeah out of nowhere addiction who also
doesn't isn't sure what he wants okay so
he's just holding him for dear life okay
he's just [ __ ] holding him for dear
life yeah yeah yeah yeah and
he just fighting him off but jake
doesn't know why he's holding him or
what he's gonna do yeah okay the main
crux of it he doesn't know what he's
gonna do okay and they're almost
fighting but they want to [ __ ] yeah
take off the [ __ ]
yeah
if i go out on my
in
hang on
if a girl said to me
i'm a sucker for deep conversations and
i'm like yeah yeah yeah and she's out i
want to know
how that whatever she said why would a
hairline so far back
i would just grab i'd be emotionless
and i'll just grab her here and i'll be
holding it here not knowing what i'm
gonna do next because if you haven't
processed it yet
i have not processed a single thing i'm
just holding her by the scruff of her
neck so she can't get
[Music]
punchline
[Music]
and my mind needs to process what the
[ __ ] because i'm thinking there's no way
you said that there is no way there's
just no way you said you let me in
i'm a sucker for deep conversations you
sat up i was about to bring in out like
the historian yeah yeah
and and then i want to know why that
hairline's so far back
i said that my face was straight and
i'll just grab her
my heart is just racing
[ __ ] sake man
oh funny
that's funny
this is a
dm conversation on twitter cool this is
the girl does it curve my man to the
left yeah when i got hiding it i have to
hide it i have to hook it under my thigh
no cap she sends him her number straight
away now
his reply
isn't that your baby daddy your me in
your media her reply focus
[ __ ] focus
[Music]
i lie
focus
[ __ ]
jesus christ
does it curve these yaps love a curved
dick scraping the sides they love it i'm
veg my dick's just straight out
mine's just bang straight bro my [ __ ]
don't curve whatsoever
that's hilarious
i was just casually drinking my water
after a workout today then i deeped i
didn't come to the gym of water
how livid would you be
fam casually
your boyfriend in the ps4 party is
fighting for his life because he said he
loved you
oh
bro these these man
playstation chat is toxic
facts like because he said he loved you
just jokes one thing about a [ __ ]
they know how to hide a baby
[Laughter]
yeah
yo
yo
found us jokes my back hurts that's
actually [ __ ]
funny and bro when they come clean
they just say bro i'm going to london
what for i need to visit my son
what i need to visit my son
and now you're the enemy you're either
with me or against me i need to see my
[ __ ] son i haven't seen him in months
that took me [ __ ]
he thought he lost his phone whole time
i'm going through it with my case on it
i saw that [ __ ] tweet family
deception
imagine i could never imagine
where's my phone and she's just on her
phone like i don't know i don't know
just scrolling i don't [ __ ] know i'm
sorry what i don't know i don't know
where it is just just bang this one
you've probably seen it got sent to us
bear the cold the food thing
you can read it read it read it
read it please i need to hear it out
loud
this girl
[ __ ] this girl said she enjoyed the
date but she's not interested in the
second one because i blew my food to
call it down
what's wrong with you girl what's wrong
with you laughs fam imagine what's
actually really important why aren't you
giving the girl that it because you roll
up some [ __ ] tagliatelle and give it
just just before you you're about to
much you want to enjoy you don't yeah
and that's a dreading as well
so we're not allowed to blow it yeah but
we're also not allowed to eat a hot goat
we just have to firm the burn
let it burn your [ __ ] tongue on some
usher things oh my god these men are
crazy this one
triggered me
did anyone else's parents make them go
to sleep two weeks early before to
prepare for school
two weeks early yeah so go to sleep
early for two weeks before breakfast oh
you need to prepare let's go fam every
towards the tail end of summer oh my god
towards the tail end of summer always
9 p.m times i'm in bed and the sun is up
the sun's up and there's use on the
streets
bikes everything roller blades
i was livid well my dad yes fun story my
dad gave we used to send us to out to
bed uh
this is
this is such a black dad thing to do
he didn't give a [ __ ] right so this is
so embarrassing
i had to get into a full-fledged
argument with my dad yeah to get rid of
a bedtime family
my dad sent us to bed at half 10 30 yeah
from when we were born
to when i was literally like 16.
okay we were born you know bro i
remember we were used our bedtime was
half ten and i used to feel lavish i'd
be in the in school like year three year
four yeah yeah i'm like listen fam when
i go to my dad's on a weekend it's a 10
30 yeah no one can tell me nothing i'm
brushing my teeth for 10 30 not a minute
sooner yeah
i'm basically up whenever i work yeah
yeah practice
my dad's sick yeah
i got older and older and older the
thing never changed
i used to say fam dad please we'll scan
on when it's bedtime
and i said you need to learn to have a
routine now bro i sleep here once a week
bro i'm sleeping once a week bro
and i remember i was literally like year
nine year nine
and when it was bedtime my dad used to
say like i said brush my teeth for 10 30
minutes late sooner my dad would say
teeth time
from from i'm telling you i was like 15
yeah i had a bedroom staying at my yard
for the weekend yeah we went downstairs
to pick a dvd yeah my dad said teeth
time
my boy said what did he say what the
[ __ ] it i said fan nothing nothing
nothing about this i was like not enough
enough enough for nothing he's just and
he was like what did he just say teeth
time we were in year 10.
he said your dad should say teeth time i
said yeah
he just reminded me to brush my teeth
before i fall asleep because he knows
it's going to be a late night
we're going to be watching movies and
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i found i've never been so modified
we're on holiday i said dad please
i'm [ __ ] 15. you can't be sending man
to bed and i said a man needs a routine
son i'm on his routine i said bro i
sleep at your yard once a week i don't
think you understand how funny that is
james well i was living he took i had to
literally just like drill it into him
now please dad this is embarrassing at
this point oh at mom's i'm out till 1am
i'll come to you i didn't send a man to
bed at 10 30.
i've got company you're showering teeth
time don't embarrass me like that
[ __ ]
from where my boy i remember his name
was lewis
lewis jones he looked at me and said
what did he say did he just say teeth ty
the way he pronounced the th in the
teeth i want to rock his jaw i didn't
want my dad's jaw after it i said i
[ __ ] hate it here
teeth type
humiliated
[Music]
you